[music]
>> The next on my list is
Brother Muhammad Fadli.
His expectation number one is My
expectation from DTP is to become a
qualified full-time guy.
This is a new thing. Qualified full-time
guy.
You have to first define what do you
mean by qualified?
If you mean a certificate qualifies you,
a qualified full-time guy.
Is it better to be a qualified full-time
guy or an effective full-time guy?
My answer would be effective
uh guy. Because the title of the show or
the program is
let's become effective guys.
Qualified?
Every person who's qualified is not
expert in his field. I know many gold
medalists
in the field of medicine, but they
aren't successful doctors.
For your information,
I'm not a qualified guy.
Neither I say Deedat was a qualified
guy.
What do you mean by qualified is
different. If effectiveness gives you
qualification, that's a different thing.
I consider Sheikh Deedat as an icon for
the Muslim ummah.
He has inspired tens of thousands of
people including myself.
And may Allah grant him Jannah.
His qualifications
in education field was only standard
six.
More important is to be effective.
Be successful.
That is the reason
the theme
of this program is let's become
effective guys.
You may get a certificate
if you perform well,
but if you don't implement it,
the qualification is there,
but that will not
get you a ticket to Jannah until you put
it in practice.
Point number two.
In other aspects, I hope
to be able to share the knowledge
acquired through this training with
others around the world.
Inshallah, the knowledge of technique.
Inshallah.
Number three,
to draw nearer to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
Inshallah.
Number four, to improve the Dawah team
in Southeast Asia.
Inshallah.
At present, are you a full-time Dahi or
part-time Dahi?
Part-time. So, inshallah,
you'll become a full-time and improve
the team, inshallah.
Point number five, to be able to conduct
own training programs.
Inshallah.
Number six, to convey the true message
about Islam based on Quran and sahih
hadith.
Inshallah. Number seven, to be able to
clear misconception about Islam.
We have a few days kept only
to reply to the misconception of Islam,
and that's one of the sessions we'll be
doing, inshallah,
for a few days. May Allah fulfill all
your true expectations
and convert the qualified to successful
and effective, inshallah.
With the Azan in China,
his first expectation is to learn from
the world-renowned
Dahi, Dr. Zakir Naik.
Allahu alam.
Allah alone knows.
I pray to Allah, may he accept my
efforts. So, accepted Dahi, you know,
accepted Dahi
is better than effective Dahi, also.
May Allah accept our efforts, inshallah.
And may Allah
not hold me responsible for people
speak about me, and may he make me
better
than what people think about me. Amen.
Number two, to enhance my Dawah skills
and knowledge.
Inshallah. Number three, to be able to
explain Islam
and to answer misconceptions about Islam
to non-Muslims.
Inshallah.
Do you know why are we going through the
expectations?
Why are we going through the
expectation?
Yes, brother Zamri bin Nooh.
So that let's say if we have a
expectation that we cannot get over here
before we came, so that we can correct
the and we can we can make it uh So that
you're not disappointed. Yes, exactly.
At the same time as a da'ee, we should
know our mad'u, our customer. So we
should cater according to the
expectation. Uh that's one of it I can
see here.
Yes.
What brother Kamarudin said that as a
da'ee, we should know what the
expectation so we can cater. But if the
expectation is not, for example, he
expects to become an expert on
Christianity.
So I will not give it to him. I'll say
why are you wasting your time?
So I want to know your expectations
so that I'll tell you
as experienced da'ee
that this what you're asking for is
waste of time.
There may be an occasion you're asking
for something which I have forgotten and
I may add to it.
Maybe.
But because this course is designed, so
the expectation if you make it clear at
the beginning, the person will not be
disappointed. And always
if you get more than your expectation,
you're more happy.
So if there are certain things you
expect
and if we clarify in the beginning that
this is what you'll get. But I realized
that when the person said he wants to
become an expert on Christianity, what
he meant was
he wanted to do da'wah to the
Christians.
I got it. So what is behind your mind,
inshallah, we'll be fulfilling, but the
phrasing may be wrong or your
expectation may not be what you actually
desire.
I'm sure you don't want to give a talk
on Christianity and teach and spread
Christianity, correct? Your main aim is
da'wah. So we know that we want to
correct the expectation.
Because we believe, masha Allah, all of
the people come here have come for the
sake of Allah
and they've come, inshallah, to please
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and to be an
effective da'ee, so that they can
fulfill the responsibility what is on
every Muslim inshallah.
Point number four, to be able to give
others
inspiration to da'wah.
If you become effective,
it's part and parcel.
you start inspiring others inshallah.
And the best example is Sheikh Ahmed
Deedat.
Point number five,
to learn my own weaknesses and to
overcome it, hence to be competent in
da'wah.
Inshallah, that's a good point.
For a person to know their weakness is
very important.
And to know their strength is also very
important.
So that you can overcome your weaknesses
and utilize your strengths better.
Inshallah. Point number six, to be able
to engage
in dialogues and debates with other
religions.
Inshallah, when required, a da'ee should
be able to do that. And inshallah, this
da'wah training program will give you
an insight
and a training on debating skills also.
Point number seven, to be able to give
the true message of Islam to Muslims by
chance and Muslims by choice. That's
good, masha Allah. That means some
people have become Muslims only by
chance and then the faith deliver the
right message and some people are
reverts have chosen by choice. Also to
deliver to them the true and the correct
message. Inshallah, may Allah subhana wa
ta'ala make it possible
that all the seven expectations as per
the Quran and Sunnah be fulfilled
inshallah.
The next in my list is
the Abu Shahris.
His first expectation is to increase my
Islamic knowledge.
Yes, you will increase, but as mentioned
earlier, it's not a knowledge-based
training program, but I've heard
comments of
most of the participants who said
that you said it's not knowledge based
but you got ocean of knowledge, fine.
For me what is a drop maybe ocean.
It differs.
But inshallah you'll be having the basic
knowledge of the one inshallah.
To learn the skills to be a professional
die.
I don't know.
So now you'll be only a full-time die
not a full-time die and a full-time
businessman.
You know I am
a full-time die and a part-time
businessman.
Full-time die and a part-time
businessman not counting the average if
I calculate normally I do a calculation
and you know people tell me you're
smoking so much you're sleeping less
your health will what will happen maybe
my lifespan will come 5 years less.
Fine.
Now in my youth age
a normal person when he works in a
company for 9 hours or 10 hours in our
company 10 hours but taking out the time
for salah and the lunch break you
actually give 7 and a half hours.
When I spend 17 hours in the with salah
time it will be 15 hours so it's
actually double.
Though I'm giving double
in my balance time
I do spend on average
about
3 days a month
for my business.
So I'm a part-time businessman but the
Allah puts in 3 days
is multiple time more than an average
businessman.
Please don't ask me how much I earn.
I don't know.
What I earn in the field is million
times more
than what I earn in the business.
But in terms of value for the other
world I think it's very
Allah gives 100 time more than what I
require.
That is the work.
If you read the life history of the
Sabah
of the one and all may Allah be pleased
with him.
It's the same that whatever he used to
touch used to turn gold.
When he went to Medina and when people
wanted to help him, he said, "No, I
don't want help. Just show me the
marketplace."
Why? He went to the market and came
back. Class.
A die he should also know management
skill.
But it's not possible for everyone to be
multifaceted.
And Allah sees your near and
alhamdulillah Allah has
blessed me in my part-time business
also. Mashallah. But never does it ever
obstruct me
and I pray to Allah to keep it that way
and not deviate me
to reducing my time for the hour.
And it's good
to be a part-time businessman.
And many of the Sahabas were
mashallah businessmen.
But it never prevented them from doing
the hour. Alhamdulillah. Point number
three, to learn more effective ways to
do dawa and better communication skills.
Inshallah.
Point number four, to learn the art of
continuous learning and continuous
improvement.
But have you got a hint of this? Yes,
I've got a hint.
>> Mashallah, good. Keep it with you and
share it with others.
Yeah, but the key Yeah, but wait, it's
just the hint. I want to learn the art.
Oh, you
See, many a time
you give a key and the person keeps in
the pocket not knowing that's a master
key. But you ask for a key, I give you a
master key.
Then you ask me, "Where is the key of
that lock?" I don't You asked me for a
key of one lock. I give you a
master key. Then you're asking me,
"Where is the key of that lock number
three?"
I give you a master key.
Did you get the answer?
I'll think about it. Inshallah, I'll get
the answer later. You didn't get the
answer? Who got the answer? Raise your
hand.
Master key of success. Master key of
success I get.
>> Ah, now you got
If Allah helps you, none can overcome
you. If Allah forsakes you,
then none can help you. So, let the
believers put their trust in Allah.
Let the believers put their trust in
Allah.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allahu Akbar. Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.